and we're back standout podcast on
standout tv
have you boys heard
so have you not heard yeah that the
oscars because we all watch the oscars
you know what they're saying is
only diverse films will be considered
for the best picture
how do you not feel about this is there
any more on that because what the hell
does that mean
so basically what they're saying is the
cast from what i'm reading here
and there's a little case study by the
bafta baftas and all that
the cast has to meet a certain
criteria over diversity
of diversity that would be sick and it
would make sense
if it was the crew the the people
working behind the camera
they should have quotas for diversity
does that make sense i love that yeah
because
when you depict when you're depicting
something of uh
like we said um was a korean food like
parasite
parasite cleaned up everything last year
how was how was the brilliant film
brilliant film how was that gonna have a
random black person
a random jewish person a random muslim
person just to hit the uh and also
women as well as women yeah yeah
um so i think i think i think it's
[ __ ] actually i think we're in such
a
uh a pc state where companies are going
to start doing this and you
people are going to be getting jobs if
but if they're not the if they're not
the best person for the job
i i don't want to get a job just because
i'm black that's what i mean and no
way so aren't we living now in a a pinch
of salt
state it's like it's it's got yeah it's
gone too far
everything that that that we were
fighting for was
relevant is a [ __ ] understatement it
was more than relevant
yeah but how has been taken and
and how how
it's lost his meaning like that's that
that's almost ridiculous yeah
and i don't think any and to fight for
equality
is is one thing yeah so we just want you
well you want the same
point if if i go for a job interview and
i don't get it
because i'm not good enough that's fine
if i
go for a job interview and i get it
because i'm black
and there's other people who are better
than me that's still not fair bro
no one wants that yeah nobody wants that
black people to
what nobody wants that yeah so for the
oscars to say
diversity on screen is a bit backwards
diversity behind the camera
that's what we need more of let's get
women let's get women behind the camera
let's get let's get back people behind
our camera who are good at who are good
at their job who are brilliant at their
job
in front doesn't make sense how are you
gonna have like there's all those period
dramas
um downton abbey where you were you
gonna are you gonna throw out
are you gonna throw f in there like
randomly
[Laughter]
it doesn't make any sense that you say
if
even like if you're telling a story that
doesn't
call for diversity i don't get it it'd
be like
you won't put a lot of white guys in
boys in a hold or something exactly
so this isn't going to start until 2024
so people have time to exactly
yeah yeah exactly they're putting
um best picture
starting with the 96th academy award so
it's for best picture
so and they're saying they have to hit
two of the four quotas
and you know what this is doing as well
for
the elderly white men who run the
[ __ ] business film business
it's making it's making the gap worse
bro because now they have to do this
[ __ ] and they
they're people who don't like being told
what to do in it so they're [ __ ] you
know
that's what i'm saying that's what i'm
saying if
if if you have to do something you're
not doing it generally from the bottom
and you're not gonna do it real like
you're doing it just to meet like
guidelines and then they'll think oh
we're not racist we've hit the [ __ ]
four quarters
exactly
so he kind of gives them a get out of
jail things and and that was well aren't
you going to look at something like oh
they've made the
the main character yeah because they
haven't existed this isn't really
like this doesn't it yeah yeah like it's
just but they've been doing that for a
while
to fit agendas and modes whether it's
black white or
yeah but the the ruins they've ruined a
lot of the um
of the disney remakes because they've
made sure
yeah it's it's a weird thing because
it's good but i think how they've
executed it is too conscious it needs to
be a subconscious form that's the whole
point of it needs to be a subconscious
form
it needs to be subconscious needs to be
the norm rather than rather than okay i
have a piece of paper here okay so we
have this okay so we have the same sex
marriage okay so we have this in the
film okay so we have it this needs to be
a bit more like benny honey yeah
that makes sense that makes more sense
what do you mean you know actually
cheers
the original she was black she's white
no exactly no but that's why that's why
that's where i disagree because
i think if you write something you could
just write a new story make a new annie
make a new empowering
[ __ ] 2020 black annie called [ __ ]
things are being done now to fit an
agenda
it's [ __ ] it's like it's like the
james bond [ __ ] james brown was written
to be a a higher class white i didn't
give
real close wife
and he's in he's in that world he's
you think israel's over is going to be
there james but yeah she could not
stirred he's going to say
i could have a red strip and a rum and
coke so right so i don't agree with it
just write stuff write i knew something
that's why that's why it's sick to have
like
black panther black there's no point of
making superman black
you you you make you make these people
you just make yeah
you write it to who they were true to
the origin yeah
i i
all this like making stuff for an agenda
stop me watching certain things
because like um
don't get me wrong that i will this this
may destroy you
this man that was brilliant that was
brilliant but then i felt some things
were just done in that to suit an agenda
i've read so much about it i think
because we know her as a writer we know
she where she's coming from genuinely
from yeah
she's london yeah she's real but then
i think it's very very autobiographical
yeah so it's coming from a woman yeah
yeah yeah i thought it was brilliant
but then and even you said to me zombies
he's trying to be very like careful oh
yeah
and the conversations i had about it
were brilliant like straight aft after
each episode yeah
some brilliant conversations yeah and it
and it opened and it opened
i opened up some six that's the thing
though like can we just talk about
things now that people might just jump
on us and be like oh no this is what you
say you like
it's not it's not you're going against
the grain basically it doesn't matter
yeah for saying something
i felt like they were doing a lot of the
lgb qt
plus i felt a lot of it was
a service like i felt like maybe they
felt like they had to
no she didn't she didn't have to you
didn't have to but there's no there's no
there's no harm
in doing that because stories and voices
that
uh don't have a voice in media
it's there's nothing wrong with giving
them a voice there's nothing wrong with
giving them a voice but
and but then this is where i'm saying
like
oh we do like maybe i'm just taking
things too much with a pinch of salt
i feel like maybe it's like i didn't
think some of it was
like genuine like it was like some of it
maybe didn't have to be in like we could
have
known while gone like we sort of known
like we didn't have to see like
it's hard like like the dude's like like
like i don't i'm not holding backwards i
don't think
no no no i don't think the guy the
episode where the guy
um wanting to bang a girl
that's brilliant no i don't think like i
think
a lot of i've if i'm speaking a lot of
gay
people i know they know like they don't
have that conflict that's
as a young gay black man in london
is very different the gay people the gay
friends you're talking about
are they black or white i'd say both
you're lying but i'm not lying i'm not
lying brother
the confidence is there they know you're
right you're right there's more
conflicts in a straight person in oh no
i might be gay i don't i've never really
i've never like i don't know i haven't
met
a gay person that is like i've only
slept with
like who i like in terms of women and
men and then
suddenly like hitting twenty-five
village you know what maybe
so that's what i see so that's why you
should have saw that story as another
thing
oh [ __ ] i didn't even think about that i
didn't think people's stories or people
of people's confusion about sexuality
could be like that because you've got
your friends who are
confident in their sexuality that is a
0.001 percent of an iota of the gay
people
even in the [ __ ] city you know i mean
yeah yeah so i think
i think i think you've been kind of
walked by the the current state we're in
which is completely fair because yeah
which i'm not taking
anything real yeah i think you're right
with what you're saying
generally that's to think
uh to to give that voice and to give
that story
in in a different angle where he was so
confused
and he didn't feel right about sexuality
so he tried to sleep with a girl to see
if it would feel right
and it didn't and he told her she was he
was gay and she cost him
um and she she had jungle fever and she
loved black man
yeah yeah um
well on that topic where do you stand on
his responsibility to tell her
because i found that interesting i
thought that that whole show was trying
to pose so
that was a pretty demonstration that's
not rigged that's enough that's
yes and that's another great that's
another great conversation that i had as
well it's just like
i was saying ah it's weird
i don't know because i was saying yeah
he probably should have told her and
then who was it was saying no
why why why why does he need to tell her
about his sexuality
i'm on that side if he had
a disease
agree to take him back home and agree to
have sex with him why did you just go
well before we do this i need to tell
you that
i'm getting that slept with men
why no i don't forget to tell you i'm
i'm saying myself i don't think it's
though
because i because my argument was before
yeah he what he
probably should and then he was
completely opposed and i'm like
well if you're with a girl yeah yeah
and you during a club or whatever you
bought at home and you're just about to
get out she goes well stop
i just got to tell you that i'm actually
a lesbian but i'm just like
but nothing different you still go
through it
you'd still do it though and then be
like afterwards
then you talked after it'd be like so
maybe you'd be like so
did i turn because maybe a woman
wouldn't want to sleep with a guy to
sleep
with you sleeps with guys and that's
fair today that's yeah that's fair
that's totally
fair yeah that's totally fair question
why is that fair
you can because you should go every year
you can yeah no no yeah
that's the point
sleeping with you when you were
attracted to me bro
because i said with a guy you don't want
to see me yeah
you sleep with whoever you want bro yeah
if
bro i wouldn't rob you could sleep with
a girl because she's you could not sleep
with a girl because she's wearing dolly
shoes brother and
you're like her crepes are dead
a girl could not sleep with a man like
because she don't like long hair
a girl could not think of a man because
because he because he's not because he's
had
sex with a guy it doesn't matter brother
each of your own it doesn't it's like
certain things are just like preference
over
over what's the word prejudice
preference over prejudice you're not
[ __ ] homophobic
if you don't want to sleep with someone
who's that's how i that's how i see it
anyway
yeah just do what you just just it's
your preference bro
yeah exactly yeah it's your preference
yeah
it's like saying it's like some people
might get on something if they're like
no
that's like that's like a white that's
like that's like saying oh yeah why a
white girl is racist
because she only has sex with black men
exactly exactly it's true though isn't
it you're you've been quitters yeah but
some people gather
to your own some people get absolutely
destroyed for their preference
well preferences go down to the most
minor
menial things bro oh yeah like you said
someone's trainers could be like yeah
bro it's dead dead a girl smokes a
cigarette it's dead for her
a girl's got a girl's got you know the
nobody she's half like picked off
it's dead for her you know
harry's never lost her girl's nails in
his life it's dead for her when when the
air force is all bent up it's dead for
her oh you're like that's when you're
live
yeah that's when you're lying like
you've never gone to a festival you're
just saying
something yeah puffing you're lying with
that
what the dead air force yeah nah man
that means she got her feet a
tank him thank him that's fine
yeah they're bad to the oscars but is
this going to affect
film in the long run of course
yeah creativity is now going to be down
to date
data is creativity not already down to
data
bit partly yeah but it's down to what
audience want and now that they're
thinking the audience want to see
uh a black person in karate kid now the
audience was thinking
isn't it
thinking they want to see [ __ ] yeah
anything in yeah it's
stupid bro they're stupid friend would
would the notebook work with two black
people
see you're [ __ ] you're not [ __ ]
you know it wouldn't bro
why would it not work or lose a bit of
authenticity yeah why would they lose an
authenticity exactly
anywho no no it's a great question why
would you use this
work
that was modeled like oh but it's
different yes i'm saying i'm saying
a a coming of age love story that isn't
hip hop so full
in all of those like common of age black
stories there's always like
a moment of like the street in it so
like oh no did you hear someone got shot
oh there's always a moment of trauma
that is street in it
or all the or the girls getting abused
there's some sort of
trauma yeah there isn't just like two
people falling in love and it's
brilliant this is brilliant love story
like all of these
all of these [ __ ] commentary what's
the other one with the
fault in our stars and all those dead
[ __ ] rom-com type films yeah
all the black ones have to have some
sort of well
no i'm reminding the audience
of that you of the way you not live
but it's
like films like things happening ends
the way people at top north
like that's reality that's what he's
saying
that notebook stuff to me is um but you
can do very culturally different to me
i think that's very why though it's love
exactly
it's love why is it culture different
it's love basically you're telling me
that there can't be a coming of age
love story between two people that is
just a beautiful love story yeah
without there being a moment yeah
oh you meant a street fighter
you know what they can be they're fully
camping is there a film about that is
there a feel like that
nope there's not broth the only one
that's close to it is the one
where it's a black woman and a white man
is oh that one where
they're not allowed to
together and like the police are
harassing them she even goes to a
different state to have the baby and the
police
sometimes get onto her there we'll let
them be together oh it's a
very good film sick love story recently
and uh they got arrested and then they
went on the run yeah
queen and slim queen and slim yeah but
but like rick said in that film there
was still killing
there wasn't just a lovely story still
police and killing in that
yeah there wasn't just a simple this
that's my boy
meets girl falls in love together
beautiful beautiful moments pianos
playing
in an
and [ __ ] in it and he can't remember
anything he loves her so much yeah so
let that happen to the guy
like he the next one is they they go
apart
right they break up that's the [ __ ]
trauma yeah yeah no round of fights
shooting
no random shooting
how is what so black people don't black
people don't like them films
that's what it is you do that with every
film yeah
every film you don't watch boys in the
hood because because you relate to that
no it wasn't bro yeah it wasn't that
real cheesy
[Applause]
do you feel like do you feel like
i don't know
as a black man elbow you can answer this
as well
but as a batman elbow is black
do you feel like when you've grown up
you have to have seen boys in the hood
you have to have see
but also the english classics do you
feel like
you have to have seen those films i
don't know if you have to you just do in
it
and you know so why is it both white
white
you know because when you were younger
because someone's like to you oh bro you
have to and you
it's not after it's just on in it it's
just on it's not just
part of your culture that's what it is
which is not just fun
no but i'm saying do you feel like we
have to have watched
all these films i think there's a black
thing i think that's a culture thing
because um all my white brothers on my
estate would have seen
exactly the same films exactly the same
music
if i was if i was born in saint albans
or something um
who knows both i might see in the states
my
harry hasn't seen all my friends are
just not there
but then but then but then
oh you've seen green street in it yeah
you've seen obviously the business
in the business yeah that's what i mean
but i've seen the business but there's
some man like
some man but have you seen the business
exactly some um exactly somebody like
you know i ain't even seen the business
so
some or some guy might be like i've not
seen lock stock and two smoking
i'm just saying is it do you feel like
because you're
a certain color of that is there certain
films you that you feel like certain
colors have watched that
has happened yeah i don't because like
i don't i don't at all i don't have a
tool family i remember back in the day
bro when i when i was very young
all the road man they used to love i
don't know how old you meant remember
the oc
perm i've never
from um [ __ ] ryan this guy from um
gotham yeah yeah no i like this
i watch this one i don't know see the oc
was
dead that was basically the first
kardashians basically but like written
it's like living in the hills no the
hills and all that was the first thing
yeah all of that [ __ ] but roadman loved
that
that's a totally different type of tv no
that's what i'm saying like
if you're black you just watch certain
[ __ ] i'm not saying you've just been
but do you feel like that what i was
saying was you feel like
some people because of that felt like
they had to have seen it
you just gravitate towards
it's not yeah it's not there's no
there's not a [ __ ] right rights of
passage like
there's not right some passage but i was
like
you don't have to but to be engaged in
the culture i think you have to
make any sense i tried to say it not
just like natural as well like because
like borrowing dvds off of your cousins
and [ __ ] no but but naturally someone
would say to this film sick watch this
yeah but you know and then but then the
film they're always giving you is
that type of like you're jackson
you're right as you get older and your
and your friends demographic gets wired
in there yeah and then you maybe stare
then you stop and you're into more stuff
but i think i think that's totally
irrelevant
to my point about certain stories
working or not working just being a
black cast yeah that might be a random
riff
it was random yeah but um
love story between two two black kids
two black teenagers yeah and it just
yeah and they're just a moist this has
to be a trauma
it's something yeah exactly they're
always something that's happened
always right conclusion conclusion is
the oscars
conclusion is at the end of the day did
you say those as a [ __ ]
look what they did to kevin hart this is
another thing kevin hart
has given our
his whole documentary is that i'm not
apologizing he said he said he said he
said
he said what i'm gonna say is i'm a
different man now but if you want to
cancel i'm not part of this council
culture so i will not apologize in order
to do my job
yeah i mean i mean when the oscars don't
he didn't apologize because of the
oscars he apologized when it happened
yeah
ages ago exactly but then he he was
supposed to host
the oscars and they said can you
apologize for this tweet and he said no
i'm not part of this cancer culture
number one i've apologized for it
already yeah yeah i'm not involved in
his cancer course you still haven't
still gained his money why am i why are
you going to apologize for something you
said five years ago if you do
and he's a comedian firm comedians have
comedians
have creative license to take to not now
that shit's been affected
yeah this is another thing this is a
lovely like this is nothing because did
you see what's that one is it family
or whatever yeah everyone's getting on
family
that's hilarious it's hilarious but i
haven't seen the [ __ ]
twitter world of that i'm [ __ ]
getting on family you can't
you say because there's a thing when
basically a man
he's like a shadow and he takes all his
boxes and his dick's massive
black man and they're saying oh so now
you're saying all black men have big
dicks you can't say tell them
like it's just loose now like you can't
like
family was funny but obviously comedy in
that
comedy in that has been absolutely
jamaicans always go for
big big bbws that was hilarious yeah but
yeah
i've that comedy especially bro it's
been affected but i say no one is exempt
from a joke
exactly yeah yeah no one takes it from
you there's certain people
who who are [ __ ] bear
sensitive for some people i suppose
the
unlike the netflix and youtube you've
never got a [ __ ] one on youtube
yeah like like some of the [ __ ] i was
watching the american office the other
day
and some of the stuff they were saying i
was just like it was [ __ ] funny
i was like if they dropped that now
yeah there's certain things that you see
and you're like yeah this joke little
britain's not taking off netflix isn't
it yeah
i love it is that friends episodes that
have been that have been cancelled
friends episodes bruh and even joe rogan
didn't his whole
um catalogue of podcasts get moved to
spotify
exclusively but they took out some
episodes that were a bit
like some controversial episodes
but at the end of the day listen let's
just let films be good and just pick
films for just being good but like
you're saying ricky
yes have some diversity behind the
camera and unconsciously so
so i get i get their sentiment but like
i said they're just bad
it's for people like us to step up and
just make a [ __ ]
coming-of-age black film what am i going
to be doing in [ __ ]
the queen from the crown is that it's
cool dear friend
it's true and how's that going to work
though
they always find a way to do it and
we'll see in it we've got two years to
find out and we'll see so you agree with
it doesn't it you like it
no no no no i don't like it no oh i just
want
things to be real and i just want things
to be good i just want
to be normal the worst one before is
that harry potter
jk rowling keeps like just randomly
being like oh yeah there was a guy who
was gay and hufflepuff and just
new plane it's just like uh hermione was
white my whole life growing up
now you're going to tell me that
hermione is black jk rowling was like
yeah she might be she might be black can
you step one
the why didn't you make it out in the
[ __ ] film yeah
with the curly hair the cat she changes
into is a ginger cat
and because we know how casting calls
work they literally wrote yes
the description of harry needs to look
like this white boy young looking
glasses
nerdy looking white
and if you're into harry potter and love
harry potter anyway would you go watch
the new ting
and care that hermione was is a white
woman still
you wouldn't you'd still watch it
because you love harry potter but
everything's done to serve a flight yeah
make a new one then make a new [ __ ]
exactly
it's a new story about what's in it or
they can make like it all went on to be
about harry's child
harry charles best brethren's black make
it about him
like his stories
[Laughter]
follow us on standout tv check us on the
instagram
subscribe on the youtube and we're out